[Música]
el pasado 24 de febrero el presidente
ruso vladimir putin justificó su
invasión a ucrania llamándola una
operación militar especial con el
objetivo de defender al pueblo del
donbass que según él durante ocho años
ha sufrido de persecución y ha sido
víctima de lo que calificó como un
genocidio putin aseguró que su objetivo
es la desmilitarización y la
desnazificación de ucrania líder del
kremlin en principio dijo que estaba
preocupado por la seguridad nacional del
país dada la información de la alianza
militar de la otan en europa del este
pero anunciar su incursión militar putin
utilizó una serie de conceptos y hechos
históricos para así justificar ante el
mundo y en especial ante el pueblo ruso
estas acciones militares contra el
pueblo eslavo no ofreció pruebas de los
supuestos lazos del gobierno ucraniano
con movimientos neonazis que sin embargo
sí han tenido un auge en ucrania
particularmente desde el año 2014 y por
ello entonces saludo a diego rep en
inglés historiador y doctor en estudios
rusos en la universidad de bristol
gracias a diego por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 por que
putin
el govierno ucrania es un régimen nazi
genocida que pruebas además tiene esto
el presidente de ruso
por la razón muchas gracias por la
invitación
bueno que es un tema complicado cierto
el tema de hablar de la clasificación de
ucrania si estoy en utilizar el concepto
nazi para justificar la invasión y en
ese sentido yo creo que putin hace más
bien
un uso exagerado de una situación que
existe realmente en ucrania
para justificar cierto su invasión de
ucrania es este tipo de declaración es
cierto va también en la línea de las
declaraciones que tienen que ver con
todo el pasado histórico y los cursos de
la memoria y los usos de la historia que
han existido para justificar las
acciones en el plano diplomático pero
claro eso no significa que efectivamente
existan grupos de ultraderecha
nacionalista cierto y que han tenido
cierta influencia en el desarrollo de
las acciones que el gobierno ucraniano
ha tomado desde europa y dar en adelante
y a eso entonces me quiero referir que
raúl tuvieron estos grupos en la
revolución del mar y tan es correcto
llamarlo un neo nazismo
podríamos decir que hay un es podría ser
correcto que hay un neonazi y el segundo
yo creo que hay que
hay que tomar en cuenta que esto no es
nuevo en europa es cierto tenemos que
tomar en cuenta que en alemania mismo
existe el grupo a efe de alternative
full touch plan que es un grupo de un
arraiga empleo no es cierto existe en
españa el grupo box que también
podríamos identificar como un grupo que
tiene
vinculaciones con este tipo de ideología
cierto en italia alega el movimiento
cinco estrellas
viktor orbán mismo en hungría con
fluidez y esto francia con el ix es muy
variable entonces claro hablar de neo
nazismo en europa es algo que podríamos
decir no es nuevo cierto la bien en el
caso de ucrania también existe y existe
por la razón o uno podría decir cierto
que tiene que ver con el proceso de
creación de identidad nacional después
de la caída de la unión soviética en la
década de los 90 tiene que ver cierto
con este proceso de separarse si
estuviera definirse en oposición a lo
que había sido su
por decirlo así su poder al cual está
subordinado cierto tiene la unión
soviética y en ese sentido la
utilización de un nacionalismo
exacerbado que
se define en oposición cierto al poder
ruso puede asumir en algunas ocasiones
sectores de carácter culto nacionalista
e incluso a neonazis sobre todo si que
se rescata las figuras y el todo de éste
colaboracionista que existió en ucrania
durante la segunda guerra mundial stepán
bandera cierto que si efectivamente
participó y tuvo un rol activo dentro de
la ocupación nazi de un gran ahora diego
se puede decir que como lo afirma además
el presidente ruso vladimir putin que el
gobierno de vladimir selenski tiene
ciertas implicaciones y cierto pues ese
sentido de pertenencia con estos grupos
neonazis esa esa esas acusaciones de
real lo puede estar un poco infundada
qué hay de cierto en esto
mira la influencia de
estos movimientos neonazis al interior
del gobierno actual cierto es existe es
marginal pero existe desde 2014 en
adelante la participación en la rada
aceptó el parlamento ucraniano de estos
grupos neonazi ha sido bastante pequeña
es cierto estamos hablando del 2% sin
embargo hay que tomar en cuenta otros
factores como el hecho de que el sistema
partidista al interior de ucrania en un
sistema partidista que es bastante poco
ideológico más bien tiene que ver con
redes clientelares cierto manejadas por
grupos oligárquicos entonces la
constitución de y el reforzamiento de
estos movimientos neonazis al interior
del sistema partidista ucraniano ha
tenido el efecto de constituirse y de
entregar y hacer ingresar al interior
del sistema partidista un grupo que está
ideologizado cierto y un grupo
ideologizados al interior de un sistema
partidista que está principalmente
organizado a través de partidos
políticos que son más bien máquinas
electorales
están manejando a través de estas redes
clientelares tiene un efecto puesto que
los fondos son los únicos capaces de
otorgar una línea de acción
políticamente identificable entonces
pese a su marginalidad en términos
numéricos ciertos se han logrado
establecer una agenda al ínter 6 gran ya
a partir de 2014 en adelante diego muy
rápidamente porque no quiero que se ve
que esto por fuera al término de nuestra
conversación comparemos entonces la
retórica de los discursos de selenski y
vladimir putin porque recordemos también
que los ucranianos comparan como lo
estábamos viendo con nuestra compañera
rosa pérez masdéu a hablar en beer
putting un hitler entonces como cual es
si esa retórica con puntos de
comparación y cuál ha sido la que más ha
calado digamos en el ámbito
internacional rápidamente diego
bueno yo creo que no toda guerra la
guerra
es tanto militar como de palabra cierto
la guerra por la narrativa del conflicto
cierto siempre toma un lugar importante
en la forma en tu muerte se presenta a
la opinión pública sobre todo en un
siglo en que la opinión pública tiene un
rol bastante grande que jugar dentro de
un conflicto entonces
nombran cierto a putin como un hitler
tiene el efecto cierto justificatorio
para generar una opinión pública
contraria a lo que está haciendo rusia
lo mismo que hace rusia al hablar de la
clasificación de ucrania en ese sentido
yo creo que es parte cierto de esta
de esta tierra de palabras que es
inevitable que use